Thank You Leslie and thanks everyone for
being here and thanks for having me it's
a
great pleasure first of all please
interrupt myself whenever you want you
can ask questions and I'll try to be
consistent ank you as well for the great
questions that you sent me are all
really interesting and we'll try to work
in down so i'm going to talk about water
out I don't want to be too ambitious
here what water energy climate change
and entrepreneurship too many things but
i'll try to you know to give you an idea
about some of these things i'll focus
mostly on water i have been working
mostly on water issues but i'll spend
all their issues as well let me start
talking about my organization we are
nonprofit organization the public policy
to do of California and we're a
nonprofit organization and our mission
is to inform and improve public policy
in California through independent
nonpartisan and objective research well
we are research organization and I think
that there are some questions asking
about that i'll try to answer a little
bit of this later so let's start with
presentation so now line high as i said
i will focus mostly on another view of
the california water system and i will
do three blocks of that the first part
is just a number bill after that i'll
talk about the drought nothing that you
are kind of interested and i'll finish
working a little bit about water
economics is one kind of i'm kind of
bias it because i like that a lot how
and we'll talk about a little bit of
that second part is the water energy
nexus i developed my dissertation and
the water energy nexus so i'll talk a
little bit about what are the relations
between what and energy after that i'll
talk a little bit about global change I
call that global change here I'll
explain you what what I mean with global
change and finally I just I will present
some interest interesting in
entrepreneurship ideas that's some some
project that I already developed I'm not
going to give you know but there are
some interesting things that I think
that I know because I'm in this kind of
wall and I think that they are very
interesting
so let's start with the water system
California escena is a part of a
Mediterranean climate and because of
that we have two main characteristics we
have the first characteristic is a
temporal variability we have dry years
we have wed years we almost done half
normal years it's always above or below
the normal and what it's even worse is
that we have cycles that we have three
four years for example we are right now
in the fourth year in a row of a dry
year you can see that there are other
answered for example look at this 1915
1935 was a really bad cycle learn almost
20 years of very very dry years so we
live with that we have to deal with that
the second part of this of this thing is
that there's also spatial variability
seventy seventy percent of the runoff in
California it's a north of the
Delta and seventy percent of water
demand lies to the south mostly you know
for example in the urban side two-thirds
of the population lives in San Diego and
Los Angeles area and also we have a lot
of very high value crops in this really
dry area of the southern central valley
you can see here all this red area it's
point one percent of our run off it's
thirty percent of our of our territory
so we have a temporal variability
special ability how we deal with that I
we built in the last century mostly are
really really impressive a highly
engineered water system we built a lot
of water reserved words and we build a
lot of kernels that are conveying the
water from mostly from north to the
south to to the southern part of the
Central Valley and also to Southern
California this this system has a
different
and you know the the cars are from
different owners we have stayed current
we have federal canals we have even
local local conveyance infrastructure
like the water that we doing here I'll
turn in San Francisco is coming from
hetch hetchy reservoir in the in the
close to Yosemite and this is a local
infrastructure all this impressive
infrastructure is has are really
interesting know if you can see that
it's here we have the Delta it's more or
less the half of that system because
most of the water that runs that range
in the North has to go through there to
go to the south and this is our really
fragile system we have we call that a
precarious apply hub we have a lot of
levees there because when we develop at
the sum of the agriculture sectors there
we just try to squeeze the rivers with
these levees and we have some parts all
this red part all these parts are below
the sea level because we had subsided
there after that we also have a fragile
ecosystem we have a lot of fishes some
of them that are even in in sharp
decline as well are in some of them are
endangered and we have also water birds
there and we have to take care of all
that you know all that ecosystem and
work with a anthropogenic also supply
harder but who uses the water in
California accounting for anthropogenic
and also known as Virginia water uses we
have like fifty percent of the water
used by the environment like in the sim
flows and for what wetlands and others
forty percent of these water his own
farms is used on farms and ten percent
of the total water in California is you
sit in cities most of that water is you
know it's not consumptive use you know
environmental is not consumptive use
most of urban users are returning as
well
the to a stream flows and also what is
in farms and i will make a point here
you know you can think that ten percent
of the of the total use on see this is
very small percentage but i would like
to tell you that the average or average
per capita water use in california is
100 100 eight gallons per capita per day
that's almost 400 liters per capita per
day and just two would like to to tell
that it's to between two and three times
the per capita water that are that is
used in most countries in Europe for
example you know we are using twice the
water they're big mostly because we have
a lot of outdoor use and another control
things but this is a good new little bit
fortunately California California's
economy doesn't rely any more on water
you know in the beginning of our of our
modern area in the 1850s to nineteen
fifty more or less we had a lot of
mining a lot of agriculture that was the
word the most important sectors in that
moment but right now no recreation
services and other goods are you know
are the really important part in
California that doesn't mean that we of
course we don't have we don't have to
care about that even that the California
Ike GDP it's only two percent of the
total gdp it's a you know there's is a
really important sector that there are
some counties for example in the Central
Valley where the the economy's relies a
lot on that so simply important given
that let's pass the second block is the
drought we are in our 44th year not real
severe drought 2011 was a really wet
here we had a lot of experts from the
Delta to the south but after that 2,000
2012 13 14 and 15
were really dry years I'm accounting
here water years is from october till
September then 2015 is still this
September's they were really dry years
and we are using most of all of our
reservoir storage and right now not
right now but in before the summer we
were almost in the in the same level
that was in in 1977 that was a really
really tough drought as well so when we
can have access or when we don't have
surface water storage what we do that
moment usually in California
traditionally we go we substitute that
water that surface water for groundwater
in this is a from the 1920s what we can
see here is that in some basins mostly
in the Tulare Basin and second base e
basing we have been overdrafting the
aquifers you know almost every year in
the last 80 years that's even worse in
in this you know you can I don't know if
you can see here that this is the dry
the draughts and in that moment is when
you when we overdraft more their Quivers
I'll get back to this a little bit later
but you know it's kind of a buffer of
security or insurance that we have but
we have to take care about this what we
can learn from the drought it's there
there are some good news the they have
been limited almond problems so far and
we have had a better form performance
thanks to two planning investments and
other things but there are some bad news
of course they're painful agricultural
reductions there are very very hard
emergencies in the small communities we
have an environmental water crisis that
we have to deal with talking about urban
why why urban didn't have this
in of big Brolin's mostly because we had
a also a tough draw it in the 87 to 90
91 and in that moment there are some big
cities that had really had to deal with
big problems and they after that they
saw that it was worth to invest in new
infrastructure in conservation measures
and you know regional cooperation to
increase their reliability so the
problems in the urban sector after that
were more or less predictable and they
they have they have deal pretty well in
that in this drug now we have to look
forward our supplies now are more
constable we don't have much more water
to take and you know this kind of cost
we can we can have other other kind of
sources we have for example pricing
restrictions you know one of the most
important policy and every one side was
this tired water rate when as much as
you consume more you pay but now that's
another question because there's a
lawsuit in circuits are you know we have
to deal with that and we have also water
quality problems in some in some areas
and what about agriculture this is the
result of economic research service the
USDA for you know statewide California
and what we can see from 2010 to 2014
that it's kind of astonishing is that
you know they have increased their you
know the total revenues have been
increasing and only because they have
increased increased expenses is a red
line finally only between 2013 and 2014
the net farm income decreased a little
bit it was not super hard why why was
that because you know when farmers
doesn't have one farmers that don't have
water what they do is just the low value
crops they just follow the lobola crops
but the high value crop they still
go working with them so that's what we
have been seeing and there's another
another variables in included in this
equation we have also crop prices that
have been increasing in the last years
we have a swell day no technological
change that you know it's increasing
yields and other things and and they
have good deal this is a I'll like a big
big picture of the state but I wouldn't
be fair if I talk about this because
there are some parts in the state like
like the central the South and Central
Valley mostly where they rely a lot in
an imported water and groundwater that
had been hit a lot you know in South or
Central Valley Tulare Basin and answer
Hawking basing they could they have
other sources of water and they that's
not their situation they have they have
been hit a lot and for me this is one of
the saddest stories in the drug we are
2015 California's one of the richest
regions in their world and there are
some small communities that have had
problems too hot water and if they have
on their other other small communities
that had water but was of a really
really bad quality this is small systems
with contaminate the world's and health
violations in 2013 and that's dry
domestic world's reported in April 2015
this is one of the you know among others
but this is one of the things that thing
that we have to address in the course of
future but how about the good news you
know the drought also motivates progress
on some other fronts I have been talking
about groundwater depletion we have had
a lot of disagree on water depletion one
water groundwater depletion causes a lot
of problems like for example this
connection between aquifers and a simple
rivers and you can have a disconnected
river that does not have a you know
environmental flow anymore or many
other things Joe for that reason the
Legislature passed last year the
sustainable groundwater management act
and for that the the water districts
have to implement ground water
sustainability plans in the future then
for the only things that we have to
implement that rawness and they have to
achieve sustainability by 2040 it's kind
of a long way but at least it's a step
to to deal with with this problem and
with that I think that we are done with
that with the drug things besides the
lettuce to think they're below the sea
level this is from groundwater yes it's
only get worse um yes but there's you
know it's not only because you're no
worries because all that's all that land
in in close the Delta had a lot of
organic matter there and you know they
burnt out but I'll said you know because
because I guilt or practices and
groundwater depletion yeah that was a
cause for that that subsidence let me
talk a lil bill doubt water you know
what electronics in very general way but
I think that it's really interesting to
think about this you know water has to
be treated as a public good because you
know public good in economics is
something in its a good that it's
non-excludable and no River Rouge we all
can use you know can go to Yosemite can
swim there and we are not competing with
that use and we are all enjoying of that
use water is also needed for life for
our life for environmental environmental
systems also for recreation systems and
it's a part of mankind mankind
collective heritage for dat wheeze and
water is of course a public good but on
the other side what is also our
commodity water has an economic value in
all its competing uses and should be
recognized as an economic good this is
the statement the fourth principle of
the Dublin statement
and sustainable development and what I'm
saying that you know farmers energy of
the power sector and other industrial
sectors are using water to make profit
and you know as singer it beyond beyond
live in cities there's an economic use
of water in households we are you know
when we are irrigating our loans that's
not you know it's only because we want
to be kind of more happy and that's kind
of an economic use of water in this case
if water has this economic value and we
are making profit of that the society
has to look for economic efficiency in
water use allocation you know we have to
allocate the water for kind of more
valuable uses to you to improve our
society and this is kind of part that
I'm encouraging you to think about all
the small parts that we have in this
water systems that there are many
opportunities mainly you know this might
be mainly focusing on economic and
technological to kind of look for more
efficient way to manage what you know we
have efficient technologies there's a
lot out there but i think that there's
many other that could be implemented
that's economic incentives like water
pricing subsidies or taxes to do a fish
and water use we can talk about
providing information people needs
information to know you know probably
but if you know people usually don't
know how how how they are paying how
much are they paying for what it's it's
so small that that you know they don't
care about that it's a it's a very small
part on you and you when you monthly you
know cost we have to understand
behavioral attitudes why people behaves
the way that they behave and after that
you can try to modificator behaviors are
all that we have to value environmental
resources if you if we value
environmental resources we can assign a
cost we can assign for example economic
incentives to to to bala rate that we
could
appreciate trading if we but if water is
an economic commodities it's an acai
commodity by trading it we can we can
get more useful a location we have
enhanced market we can as well reveal
market failures we if we know that
there's a there's a way that's a market
failure and a and the market can't
allocate the what an efficient way we
have to reveal it and we have to deal
with that and finally we can decrease
hartals with biopolitics with that more
or less is the first part I'll talk I'll
talk now about the what energy Nexus
this was part of my this part will be a
little bit about my dissertation more or
less and to understand that when I'm
talking about water energy Nexus I say
that in California nineteen percent of
all electricity and thirty percent of
all natural gas is used to extract move
treat and heat water that's a big amount
that stated in the California smart
energy relationship of the California
Energy Commission report in 2005 and on
the this is the this is energy for water
use on the other side we have water for
energy use for energy generation water
withdrawals for the water withdrawn for
power generation amount for the five
percent of total with revels in the
United States that's in 2010 this is all
the state from west to east this is
California the largest one we don't have
that kind of problems here a bay few of
our water is going to power generation
and most of this water is saline water
is from from the sea so we are not
competing uses but there are some other
states in you know in central part and
eastern coast the east coast that they
have you know a lot of water is going to
thermo electric power generation have to
say here that you know most of that
water is returning is getting back to
the system but anyway we have to you
know this power units needs our
reliability in the future to have
water so we have to include that in our
you know thinking so whether an energy
are interrelated in many ways for
example we have dams the dams can
produce hydropower we can there are
other power plants they need water as I
said before and in the other side water
pumping moving water large distances
water treatment wastewater treatment and
watering houses they we use a lot of
energy there we can see we the third leg
of that nexus that is called what energy
food nexus is the food production for
food production we need we need a lot of
power and a lot of water so you know
there's kind of a very complex systems
understand in my dissertation i bought a
bottom-up approach from from households
after that urban systems and after that
the basic scale I'm just going to
present very briefly the main results
this is for that the household is scale
only for heating water heating water in
our house households amount for the two
percent of total per capita greenhouse
gas emissions in California most of this
what energy sorry is used in faucet and
shower eighty percent of our and
water-related energy is important
showers and as you can see here most of
the of the water goes to outdoor and
they have the other components of I
accounted as well for the costs trying
to know which conservation strategies
are more interesting the view account
for energy conservation because I think
that when people is using water they
don't think that there's a lot of
embedded energy behind that the second
part the dissertation was analyzing the
urban water cycle these are really a
simple schema of East Bay mud is
remedies is very manageable municipal
utility district that is here the a
utility that serves Oakland Berkeley and
other cities there they have 1.5
millions of customers
and we have the dams they're upstairs
and we have to treat the water pump the
water to that hilly topography and after
that treat the wastewater but when
accounting for all these things i found
that the Holborn water cycle as a whole
a has is responsible of four point five
percent of our per capita in house gas
emissions and you can see here that most
of that greenhouse gas emissions are
induced single-family residential
multifamily and commercial and
industrial only that five percent is
water treatment pumping and wastewater
treatment only five percent of the total
urban water cycle but what it's
important from here is that for the
water utility that five percent it's
worth 12 million of dollars per year you
know this is for is bommali what I was
interested in that it was not only
trusted this is it was what are the
consequences for the water utility and
also for the energy utility if people
change their behavior if they are
changing the way that they are using
water the patterns the time patterns of
consumption and other things because
they can have a lot of changes yes
single-family it's you know multi-family
it's our kind of apartments and
residential where water it's kind of for
a group of houses and single-family it's
only your family you have one account
for yourself then the last part here was
understanding the basic scale of that we
have water yeah sorry really has gas
emissions from worries that just assume
that everyone Virgie
is youth is a certain amount of
greenhouse gas emissions or did it take
into account time of day when people
were using it doesn't that they it
doesn't take into account time of day
it's what I did here is using green
house gas emissions factor from from the
utility in this case is from PG&E
because it's the utility that is serving
but it doesn't take into account
different times of the day if these
sorts of uses could be shifted off peak
and wouldn't they potentially have
different greenhouse gas emissions dad
that was my motivation but not for the
greenhouse gas emissions because I will
explain later that but my motivation was
that there's a lot that's a lot of costs
of that peak you know the afternoon and
morning peak if for example they're
people that it's irrigating on on on
peak hours because they don't care you
know you are paying the same what if we
can change that behavior to off-peak
hours and I was accounting for costs for
for cost for the energy utility under
water utility because the energy utility
is serving the energy at the same price
and they are paying a lot that's the
other part is what you are saying
greenhouse gas emissions are different
in the treatment of the day I have a
kind of the feeling that we can't do I
have seen a lot of some of research that
that is doing what you are saying at the
feeling that if you change that peak
what is happening is that the system
reallocates the way that they are using
the you know all the power unit and in
this case you can say directly we are we
are saving because we are not using the
peak actually in peak hours we have the
less pollutant power units because we
have solar and it's kind of tricky and
we there are some many issues that are
not that the hub to be accounted but
that's a good point I I was thinking
about that as well when I did that
and the last part of that was to account
for the base in a scale you know we have
if we account for for a base in that
it's a closed system all our water
sources are related interrelated between
them we have ground water we have we
have surface water we have a recycled
water you know but they are interrelated
and we have to account in a hydrological
or and more in a mass balance system to
come for their interactions and these
water sources are is are serving two
cities AG demands through utilities or
through sub supply but also to the
environment and to power to energy
generators and we from the energy power
units we from the power unit we do that
we do energy to the grid and we get back
to this you know we have a really
complex system here and an understanding
that complex system is the first step to
try to manage it in a better way just
I'm so sorry but I don't have twenty
percent some most of the results but
what I found here this is very
simplified model for California from 84
to 2003 and what we found here is that
most of that is the urban energy you
know first five percent of the total
greenhouse gas emissions are from the
total water cycle because most of that
it's the urban eighty-five percent of
the total are it's coming from from the
cities from the Roman cycle we have here
that is this read on this red and yellow
is they are the old one cycle and after
that we have the AG and also a large
combines this big peak is the state
water project the state water project is
the the combines infrastructure from
here to LA that goes through that hatch
apiece and has to pump a lot of water so
we are using that you know this eleven
percent of our our greenhouse gas
emissions in my model would come from
there
ten percent of the total greenhouse gas
emissions related with with the water
ice you know talking about that because
it's not super big you know also in the
faces but state water project is the
largest single user of electricity in
California some years they can use three
percent of the total equity in
California they are generating
electricity after that you know they
pound the water and after that they
recover some in this case but as a
single user they're the largest one not
this year because they don't have water
to pump but and just the last is right
here in the in the water energy Nexus
this is the kind the other side is the
generation side I just wanted to say
here that hydro power cut in half by the
drop was cut it in half what the dog you
know because hydropower is highly
variable depending on the water that we
have and this last year was half of the
average what is happening here is that
because we can't build more dams all the
good site has been built already and we
are increasing population increasing
energy demand you know we have a lot of
other electricity that is coming from
other sources and in this case you know
hydropower is not really significant now
but still there are some studies that
say that probably two percent of our
increase in electricity this year are
coming from decreasing hydropower and
with that I'll take I'll talk a little
bit about global change and I'll explain
now why I call that global change I will
like this side this quotation global
scale changes in population and economic
development over the next 25 years will
dictate the future relation between
water supply and demand to a much
greater degree than we will change in
mean climate that's our paper in science
I what I want to explain here I look in
the face
what I want to explain here is that of
course that we have to take into account
climate change climate change is kind of
our availability our temperatures our
our precipitation is going to change our
patterns are going to change a lot but
we have to take into account our demands
and you know population and how we as a
society audible we are developing it's a
really important part of our models then
after that probably have seen this
before this California is getting warmer
this is temperature last year 2014 is de
la la is the warmest year on on records
but by far and what's what's that
calcium in our systems you know more
warmer temperature causes more
evapotranspiration we have less water
usually we can think about energy as
well warming temperatures in summer
increase a lot our air conditioner
demands and in this case increases
energy demands this is really important
for for water systems climate models are
predicting a shrinking in snow pack and
a lot of increasing in variability you
know a snowpack is kind of our natural
we server it's snowing in the in the
winter and we have there's no door and
then in the spring and the summer when
we use the water from farmers mainly use
the water this this snow is there is no
melt and we had that water available if
we increase our temperatures and some of
that snow falls as rain will have to
deal with this water before and we'll
have problems in with with our reserved
words because we can't some of the of
the rain that is falling on winter we
just have to release it release it
because we have to have a flood storage
capacity in this case this is going to
change a lot how we how we manage our
systems the other part that you already
know
it's a syllable wise threatens coastal
infrastructure homes and Abby that you
know this is the war's kind of
worst-case scenario for 2100 I think a
55 inch sea level rise will put nearly
half a million residents at high risk of
flooding we have as well critical
infrastructure airports what roadways
and also habitats environmental habitats
will will be affected this is that the
kind of supply-side the availability but
when we talk about demand this is about
you know we are talking here about water
this is from the dwr California water
plant an update in 2003 we are expecting
in 2050 that the hour rated crop area
will be decreasing slightly why is that
because mainly because we will have more
population and this people has to live
somewhere and this you know mostly in
the Central Valley growing cities will
will displace a crop areas this case
will have less crop area more population
and as we use a lot a lot more water per
acre in in farms it suspected that the
total amount in the future will likely
be kind of similar to know I would say
as well here that we don't have more
water in this case we have to deal with
that you know we don't have fresh water
we can we can talk about selling water
later hmm and what will happen with
agriculture this is a study from my
colleague of Medina soiree at UC Davis
this is the economic impact of climate
changes in California we can see here
it's too you know the historical climate
is the yellow one that the green is the
one day dry climate change scenario we
can see that they rated accurate will
decreased a lot the farm water use will
increase a lot but the revenues will
decrease but not so much actually will
increase in the future will decrease
world
tip to the historical scenario why is
that it's because the same that I said
before we are display will we will see
displacement in low bali crops low body
crops will be getting out and we will
have will still have high value crops
and will have increasing in yield
potentially because technological change
and other things you know that's what we
are likely to expect and finally this is
a another sad story we have a really an
aquatic ecosystem crisis till 2010 from
1975 this is you know fishes freshwater
fishes in decline a sort of freshwater
fishes we have extinct as red highly
highly vulnerable less vulnerable and
lisboa level while we are we have been
seeing till 75 2 2010 is that the less
vulnerable at pitches that are ok have
been reduced it from fifty six percent
to twenty-two percent we have increased
a little bit our extinct extinct species
from the 75 and if we run the same way
that we are running right now the system
will expect a lot of marks extinct
species in the future so we have to
think about that finally that's your
point interesting entrepreneurship ideas
but I found through i'm only going to to
show you for case cases first of all i
would like to ask you a question you
know we are talking about water draw
about dot about water crisis and always
think how many of you think that you are
aware about your water consumption and
because of that you have reduced your
water consumption in the last year's
please raise your hands I'm included
okay
so tricky thing there is little or no
correlation between general awareness of
water conservation issues and household
consumption this is stallion 2003 post
potentially yeah heaven help or you
really reduces yeah why are you now so
yeah I mean isn't it like people are
aware yeah yeah but what what what did I
tell you that I will I really like a lot
you know too it's just motivate thinking
about that is that there's no
correlation if you if you take a sample
and you asked how environment of family
are you and you say up a lot and that's
all the people i don't care there's no
correlation about these people that are
saying that there is super you know at
least these guys didn't find it and of
course that we can think about that i
just i just use that to motivate that if
you want to how or for instance gives
you can see ya yes but i'm also taking
that you'll see in the next slide
because of that it's like individual
behaviors or what people think about
themselves if you can't compare with
others it's not a valuable approach and
you know finally but our feelings
findings substantiate the role of
personal involvement and habit formation
habit formation is really important and
it's this this is the first case studies
water smart probably i don't know if
it's here is in davis is in other many
areas what is not is a company what they
develop in the last five to ten years is
just they are doing a portal that they
are working with water utilities and
what they do is every month they send
you an email or a letter in that email
war sweater and and they are saying hey
guy you are a good guy and or you are a
bad guy and they are just very simple
thing there this your water score can be
green
yellow or red and this is because they
are comparing you and all other houses
that I'd like yourself how many people
is living in your house the same how big
is your plot and a lot they are more or
less comparing the same things and what
they had fine found is that they are
creating behavioral change by enacting
social norms you know people likes to
act as normal people you know we are we
are most of the people not everyone but
mostly we were like like to be in the
normal and we do when they are telling
you you are using much more water than
others like you you'll have to take care
about that you know they they in the
webpage and in other studies that I have
found that are interesting there's a
very cost effective option of water
conservation in for example in SB mad
that I was working with with assembler
they reduced they say that in one year
they reduced by five percent the total
water consumption is blame on you know
it's only information what we were
saying before information in their kind
of right way in a very easy easy an
understandable way the second case study
is also a platform it's called water
fine it's not it's a Australian company
I think that they are now here in the US
they are working a little bit but this
was developed before three 1990s or or
in two thousand in the beginning of two
thousand and what they did is they
develop an ultra normal and product
platform and they act as a broker in
their Australia water market and what
was that why was that because they were
you know this trading sorry Australia
has a market on in hunted market they
develop it in the 80s and the trading
before was only by personal agreements
people that go to to one place and says
I want to buy your your water because my
have you know Tiger income from my use
in this case what they did what they
find it's just an institutional thing
that is not working because it's not
really useful but with online platforms
they can have they can get together
people that is that wants to serve water
and people that just want to to buy
water the third one I think that you
will knew it its nest think that what
they are doing is just pretty easy forty
percent of residential energy
consumption is a space heating or
cooling in in the United set that's data
from residential energy content
consumption survey i would agree i would
add hear about the world that i did
before that twenty-five percent in
California is a heating water it's less
in other states because we have less we
have less heating and cooling here in
California we have mild a mild climate
but you know it's a smart thermostat
that learns about your habits and just
changes or tries to optimize the energy
consumption of your house and the last
one it's I think that it's based on this
thing it's not still other thing I was
reading that it will they will start to
be felt in in December I think it's more
or less the same but in water they they
they are using a whole house water
controller and they're they're providing
information about your water use you
know kind of more detailed information
about how much water using outdoor in
another part endure another apprentice I
endure it can automatics according to
weather or other conditions okay it's
really interesting idea we can get some
benefits from there and I think I'm
amazon that's nice cartoon this is from
the 90s this is a 91 drought they were
saying that you know we can become
something like that because we only have
in the future and you have our permit to
use our slides and you know more
information you want more information
you just need to ask
with that I'm done with that we will
will will follow with the with the
questions right so we sent the questions
in advance that you folks up submitted
and there were some great ones and also
of course as always feel free to just as
yes please oh yeah the thing that sort
of help you track your water use not a
certain thing do they account for your
food preferences because you showed that
of the anthropogenic uses for water
eighty percent of that was for Niagara
clatter only 29 director to use yeah so
it I'd be like you know my parents use a
bunch of California's water living over
in New York as I do living here because
they study halls you know I think that
we have a kind of question a similar
question of that here I can answer that
now this is the so-called bill to a
water or water for water footprint of
things there's a really interesting idea
from hoekstra I think in the 90 s sub
paper I don't remember the name now but
it's our extra develop that idea bail
Barba to our water and water footprint
yeah it's a really interesting idea when
when we account for kind of
international trade and also for you
know when if it's worth to use the what
to use something here that is is
produced somewhere and is transported
here and you know we has a lot of
greenhouse footprint inside that the
same is him in in water that one point I
think that it's really interesting to
think about that and probably there's a
lot of applications of that the other
point about for example the amount i
think that water we wrote about that in
at ppac in our blog thing it was a new
york times news article
out almonds in California if you think
about kind of microeconomics I was
telling me for a farmer just want to
produce what it's more profitable for
for themselves and almost is one of the
most profitable things right now here
for all in the future won't be but what
I what I mean with that is that you
can't avoid that and it's not bad at
least what from my understanding they
are creating jobs are doing other things
water here we have the world the water
is getting back to the to the to the you
know to the water cycle again after
after the consumption and I think the
day we have to use our resources as as
better as we can if farmer can pace
another for example we are we are
growing rice here in the enclosure
sacramentum rice is the most water
intensive user or one of the most
intensive users in in in California if a
farming can change or can trade the
water use with other use for me it's not
a problem no taking into account that we
are not accounting for environmental
things or or other kind of because rice
it's providing environment ecosystem
services as well but that my impression
is that we have to account for all these
things and use our resources as bad as
you can and I think that that kind of
that thing about the island is kind of
it's an interesting idea i think that in
an international way but but not so or
in a national trade way but when you ask
the farmers is like it's microeconomics
I think I know if I if I answered your
question but that is my feeling about
that individuals we want to reduce their
water consumption that's that's why I
know that almonds use the water that's
completely sure like what are there any
tools that will help because like I can
take a shower its partners sure
otherwise be but why that's is that a
meaningful contribution right to change
in my diet yes but for example what what
I feel from your question now let's talk
about beef beef is one of the most
consumptive resources that we have when
we when we eat beef there's a lot of
water there's a lot of other resources
then and the cause needs a lot
of land to be grown then you know as if
you think about the global thing
probably we are not sustainable if if
all the humans eat the beef that we'd we
couldn't afford it and we have to think
about that for the future probably but
it's kind of the same for for what if
you are comfortable if you think about
that if you think in that way like like
how much water if we are having a
footprint that you know the wall can't
afford we will have to think about this
most of that ions are going to China
that's another you know it's as
international trade the way that it's
right now working the International
Tavia that was a question like I think
almonds are unique because like
virtually all the world's almonds like a
sort of it in California but for a lot
of products like just regular old milk
really know it was a pretty water
intensive product by itself could do you
think that it would be useful to like
for example buy milk from Wisconsin
where they don't have the water crisis
as opposed to buying them from
California right it's like where you get
these resources first go and make a
difference in terms of the various
pressures right in some areas are better
able to handle the ecological pressure
of prohibited water like
to the end state wisconsin New York etc
then how horny like is that is there a
way to kind of do that to make a more
meaningful contribution to use kind of
globalization and yes I think that
that's a good point you have I think
that the market kinds kind of regulates
that what you can't do that in some in
some clouds we are doing it subsidized
kind of things that are not working
because the market we are we are doing
this thing in here in California and
also in the United suspect international
trade you know we have to think about
it's it's useful for us to do to to
create a sector that actually is not
economically feasible here and nothing
that that's a good point we'll think
about if and actually dairy it has a lot
of trouble right now with not only with
because of that also because of that
California has a lot of environmental
regulations that daily you know that
other states doesn't have others they
don't have and they probably they have
better to go there to go there just
because they can they can contaminate
aquifers and here we have a very
restrictive but that also thinking about
as a global perspective it's not also
helpful for anyone it's the same it's
just relocate kind of bad things I guess
I'm not a good approach but we have to
think about that more so you mentioned
about were Spanish edgy
less I guess these salination plants and
like last resort more like what's the
current position of the Sanitation but
it's happening with this that I think
it's another question here what happens
with this alienation is that right now
it's so expensive that for most of the
users in California are not you know
farmers are not going to pay the cost
that the because that are this all
planned it needs to be run then the only
in the way that are working right now
the only the only potential future for
desalination plants is for urban uses
that don't have other other sources of
water if they can get water from other
cheaper sources they don't build they're
not going to build a discipline but if
they have like for example Israel or
other very stressed parts in the world
if you don't have other other resources
you little by you'll build up this whole
plan but here in California there's
another part there's some projects about
brackish desalination you know bracket
desalination it's not saltwater it's not
so intensive and you you are you can do
that for for can be affordable or or you
know feasible economically more how the
time we have eaten we've still got 13
minutes
first your question how do I just
respect as yours evaluate positive and
possibly fun testing areas for new
technologies at her promis-- for helping
with conservation of water efficiency
you track us accelerator like clean tech
open sustainable Silicon Valley and
others and do you have any advice my
advices were before more or less my
advisor the advices that I have to give
I did it before I think more or less you
know what I what I mean here is that
combining two things about my
presentation is that what we have what
these complex systems have have multiple
parts and also this kind of micro
economic theory at understanding how
people behaves how farmers do their
business understanding these both
systems there's many many points where
we can help and what we can be useful I
think and you know i think that there's
a lot of opportunities out there and in
our water stress region like california
probably you know another party don't
care about this because they have water
about our organization we have been we
are not directly trick tracking
accelerators like clean tech op open and
all that but we we have worked a little
bit or we we have been following some of
these companies for example there's not
it's not an this kind of new
entrepreneur companies but in the 90s
was are really at least in my area
really famous company called aquacraft
tin in chlorella think and they are they
what they did is that they just used a
water meter pressure meter in in the
main intake of your house and they
developed an algorithm to understand
where are you using your water in europe
in the different appliances or your
house you know it was most of my
dissertation was budget in that in that
company
that data other companies as I as I said
WaterSmart is in really interesting
things and for next year we are just now
working in a project to analyze drought
resiliency for the next threat in
California and one of the parts will be
working with water poly sorry with urban
policies which policies have been more
cost effective in the future we can
think about this and of course that
think that in the future we will have to
take we have to account for these things
most people in California aware of
climate change and impact of mouse
choices however people do not seem to be
as conscious about water consumption
from our daily activities concerning the
water shortage in California do you
think that it's possible to actively not
passively changes people behavior daily
behavior to save more water if so what
is the role of policy and mass made
think that yeah this was also about
beautiful water this a store bought a
store bought a cup of coffee requires
many times more water during the entire
you know it's also the thing out virtual
water and what a footprint I think that
we can change a lot of things and also
you know the most promising thing for me
if we can we want to reduce all venues
here in California is is outer there's a
lot of outdoor consumption here and even
more in Southern California when when we
have warmer temperatures and all that
but also in indore things you know think
that there's kind of big percentage
between five and ten even in indep in
really developed countries between five
and ten percent of water is leaking in
urban water systems you know there's a
lot to do a lot to there how can an
organization be nonpartisan when the
parties are so clearly divided on just
about average how the things that how do
you think tanks have funded and what we
think of you know what we do is research
we propose we have a board
that tries to have everyone included
both both parties are included in our
board we have a different stakeholders
we have farmers we have urban for
example we have the percent of our
quality say a situation of California
water agencies it's in our board and for
example my roller I can propose projects
that I think that our policy oriented
and interesting and if they think that
are interesting I can work for myself
like developing research and this is the
way that we work be nonpartisan it's
that sometimes difficult you have to you
have to say things that people doesn't
like and but at the same time you have
not to be an advocate of kind of you
know because they have to take you enter
into account if you just say things that
are you are they are going to hate you
it's not working you know you have to be
between these two clients i think that's
that's my thing and I day to day work is
that I just do research like before I
don't have to I'm not teaching I have
more time how do you address untangle it
the issues of the century all the land
ownership okay this is about water
rights mmm there it's asking I don't
understand fully how water is allocated
to give in a farmer and how do you
determine now who gets the water you
know its water rights what about writing
california-based him in a very simple
way where are three types of water
rights we have riparian water rights
repairing water rights is people that
it's just next to the river this is the
first water right that exists in
California and the riparian water right
is the first that gets the water and
they get all the water that they want
but they are just close to the river and
historically they have been doing so and
there's two kind of appropriative water
rights that's after the mining era a
property water rights that you ask
a permit for the government to get water
let's play 1914 impose 1914 because
there's a change in the legislation that
time and play 1914 have more privileged
on what to write a location then it's a
great joke that a friend of mine did if
you have three glasses of water or wine
and there's one appropriate one riparian
one pre-1914 and one post 1914 you are
three it's one for everyone you know if
you have one and a half one is for the
riparian and the other half is for the
Prime 1814 and postnatal 14 doesn't help
anything it's really complicated and
it's a really tricky system one of the
projects that we are working with right
now is we think that if we can we could
change that we will propitiate more
trading and that's kind of beneficial
because for example we payin it's it's
it's safe here riparian gets the water
as much as they can and for that reason
they are just saying that they are using
a lot even even though they are not
using that water because they want to so
sometimes like this year in your
mother's you are accounting for these
use that actually is not used and you
are kind of wasting that water that's
kind of tricky
what matters is the Californian
government agencies taking to bring this
into practice they are doing a lot of
things you know actually our role here
is much easier we just can propose
things we don't have any
responsibilities with boaters we thought
things they have to deal with all the
bureaucracy and also with with the
boaters and I'm bad they are doing a lot
of things in for example last year they
implemented that sustainable groundwater
management that with a lot of position
there was a lot of people that didn't
want to implement that because they are
they were pumping a lot and this is kind
of I didn't understand well it's about
the macroeconomic thing what it's
evident that they are gaining huge
importance in today's world how true is
the linear would be the year of fun in
for California and this is something
that I have been eagerly looking forward
to a while there's our Noah be do
outdoor it's really I can't send you the
link that explains really well this yeah
and what it's happening is that in the
southern part of the United States it's
likely to be more its weather but also
warmer that it's kind of tricky for us
and in the in the northern part it will
be drier then most I think that most of
the more most likely part it was salty
California was about about fifty percent
you know for California not for the rest
of the United States and the likelihood
was about fifty percent I think that in
really southern california and about
thirty three percent like from
sacramento down something like that but
there's a video you can check i can send
you the link yeah thus alienation I
think that I answered that question I
saw in your blog post that and that's
good because my first one as we said 350
and I'm curious about what sort of
technical breakthroughs you think would
be required for its success
it's technically feasible but costly do
you think with do you think that the
state would fund this affords that's the
point is like we can I think that
technically we can do it the point is
it's economically feasible and it's
actually true that it's going to give to
result in a lot of jobs and you know
it's a trade-off between things that are
going things that are on benefiting the
California and other things that are
also costing a lot of things well
there's another point but it's not
already with that is that California is
playing a kind of leading role worldwide
and we have to think how interesting is
that for us I think that it's really
interesting but prolly is costly as well
if everyone follow us that's perfect
that's not really good for us and in the
future we will have a lot less trouble
that we are expecting but of course that
it's a you know we have a lot of sectors
interacting here we have the green
economy we have the fossil fuel economy
and and we have the boaters and there
and the politicians this is so difficult
what are some of the unanswered
questions of the large and the small
scale on your field of work one of the
most thing is that's really tricky to
explain that's a controversy about
surface water about sorry about
irrigation technologies surface
irrigation and drip irrigation
technologies I didn't found really good
research that is explaining how much of
that surface water is returning from
cliffs to their Quivers because a lot of
people say that when you are changing
your irrigation technology you are
saving water and that's not directly
true it's it's in some part true but
some of the water in California that we
have this in the Central Valley we have
these two valleys that are going to the
same place
most of the water that farmers are kind
of wasting is it is getting back to the
quiver and these use it again for other
reducers then we are not wasting the
water but I don't have data to say how
much water because I didn't find it
there concrete think about that
behavioral behavioral economics i think
that's another topic and applied to
water and energy issues you know it's a
lot that is going it's going on now but
i think that there's a lot to understand
in the future how people behaves and
when an agility increases the price or
many other things like gives you
information how we are reacting to that
and i think that that's interesting
point and this is more difficult even
more difficult understand that with the
degrading sacramento-san joaquin delta
levy stronger linear patterns and
decreases the spending on improvements
it seems it's no only a matter of when
not if we should see a major disaster in
this area which could cause possibly
billion in damages millions in damages
well there is not an easy solution for
this program what do you believe could
be a first step or a solution of to this
impending creases I think that we have
to take small like small steps in very
different areas we we have to take we
will call that a portfolio approach if
you for example this this is what urban
utilities did in the last 20 years if
you only have one water source you have
a problem if you have five water sources
you do reliability it's increasing a lot
the same can be seen kind of big
management problems you we have to have
a portfolio approach could you mention
some of the ways becoming embodied eat
these projects I'll I'd beans in the
beginning that our I think that it's
talking about public policies of
California think we have internships in
the summer and if anyone is interested
figure it's open in February or march
something like that but check out our
web page
we have we have that we are almost done
we only 12 what water and energy
infrastructure improvements has found
most successful in his pain ambassador
on this success what improvements do
does he suggest California prioritizing
now the most interesting thing from
Spain but it's not potentially up like
applicable here it's our institutional
framework we are for water I'm saying
I'm talking about water now our
institutional framework we have a basin
agency that oversees everything and has
a lot of competences can curtail water
can do a lot of things that here you
can't do that because you have this
decentralized and local kind of
management of water systems these are
you know we can't go there right now
because our California Los and all that
but we can figure out how to get a more
comprehensive and integrated system to
work together and for for energy i would
say that we have we have done a lot of
real we know ourselves a lot of wind and
soil in spain it's developing here right
now as well at some cost you know we are
paying that in our electricity bill
sometimes in spain MC because it's
economical is more actually it's more
expensive right now than than other what
other energy sources for water for
example much water in California
particularly in our bed in our Bay Area
is lost and or contaminated due to the
tree decorating water pipe system how
can we change this inefficiency most
economically over the next 25 years when
a replacement is projected to cost over
1 trillion with small steps rule I said
before that there's a lot of water
leaked in urban water systems and i
think that there's a potential
technology issue they're going on i
think that there's a lot of going
working in progress
area but it's a technology issue to know
exactly where do you have your leak
you